let's talk about Lindsay Lohan you know
she had this show on own which is
Oprah's network that nobody knows what
channel it's on except for Oprah
apparently and the show got canceled he
did one season it just got counseling
had poor ratings surprise surprise and
there's a lot of drama around the show
now I actually hadn't watched the show
until we decided to do the second so I
caught up a little bit let's show you a
clip of Lindsay show I may have
addictions to certain things in life but
I'm not essentially your typical addict
that's not going I'm not that kind of
person I know the difference between
right and wrong and stupid and idiotic
and you know what's gonna bad like I
know that was raised well about my
variance but and I've seen it
but there's certain things that baby
don't there's no one around people
sometimes and I see that now we don't
usually do this kind of stuff on this
show but I thought this was particularly
interesting because it's related to
Oprah and how much truth are we getting
out of her and Lyndsey is just such a
trainer so first just let's just talk
about the train wreck part of it why are
we obsessed with train wrecks why why'd
no matter with Justin Bieber pees in a
slop bucket and yells at bill clinton
and you know amanda bynes throw his bong
out of a window
it was my bong which is that was the
upsetting part it's like why why are we
obsessed with these people well I think
you see celebrities climb very high and
you want to see them fall I mean it's
part of the kind of story that we've
conditioned to expect and so when
someone is that famous and that popular
in that Ridge you kind of expect this
this downfall aspects to happen that's
like that way the story ends yeah I
think Lindsay's been around for so long
we've seen ups and downs
I personally watched the show hoping it
would be I mean I'm more those people
who actually want her to succeed so you
thought that somehow she was gonna be
get her maiya culpa through this well I
don't know what I thought but I kept
watching so I mean it's it's tough I
mean she really is I feel like she's
trying I feel she's also very diluted
and so you kind of see that in the show
that what channel is it by the way I
know I know I DVR'd aI don't know yeah I
don't know the DVR knows yeah what do
you think what's the trainwreck
explanation because there's something
deep in the human psyche that loves
thank you well I think part of it is
actually in just a diction to narrative
and the fact that when someone reaches
the top that's if it was a movie that'd
be the end of the narrative but in life
it continues to go on so we seek out the
next part of the story we want to see
the next part of the story and I think
this is you know kind of a the
Heisenberg uncertainty principle it's
like something that is watched will be
changed and when you start pointing a
camera and throwing paparazzi around
these people at all times like that will
drive someone crazy and I think we've
seen that with so many people now it's
it's
I mean TMZ had plays this tries to
whenever somebody gets into serious
trouble and something really bad happens
team Z suddenly seems like really like
respectful yeah like we really are
praying for it's like you were a big
part of what happened here this is
someone who maybe didn't like shoot
someone but provided the gun affected
and therefore useless somebody needs to
put some of that powdered alcohol in
what the hell's his name from TMZ yeah
11 harvey levin put it in his little you
know he's sucking on that thing
constantly this remind me a little bit
of that South Park episode with you know
that humans we used to have human
sacrifice and now we're not sacrificing
these people to death but we're just
putting them up there for that so I
guess that sort of goes to what you're
saying about it there's like this deep
need in us it's really is that yeah not
as dark as the show Lindsey little
darker than what anything you said so
the part that made me really want to
talk about this though was the Oprah
connection because you know everything
Oprah's built herself on has been
actually what we think of are the
reverse of Lindsay Lohan and everyone
was like oh well she's gonna give her a
chance and Oprah can fix Lindsay Lohan
cuz Oprah can do anything but even Oprah
failed did she fail I mean I don't well
it makes me very sad the whole show I'm
still reeling yeah it's been a it's been
a tough several weeks but I I think that
I don't know it's hard because with
Oprah you kind of wonder did she come
into this with good intentions you know
was she actually trying to help someone
that is that is her her thing so we
believe that's everything but she also
wants to make money right she wants
somebody to watch the channel I think
that it's a mix it looks up for he she's
a lot of Tyler Perry programming that's
doing pretty well do we have a laugh
track and someone put your laughing but
it's doing really well yeah people love
Tyler Perry
Lindsay not so much but I think that
it's a combination of wanting the
ratings and also believing that I think
she thought she could craft a story
where it is this addict who has failed
so many times before but now she
suddenly it's a come-to-jesus moment and
Oprah is Jesus and that's like that's
what that's the show but that wasn't
what happened because Lindsay's not that
predictable and you can't kind of force
an addict into that that
narrative yeah so that's the part that I
think is interesting because this is if
that's the case let's keep Oprah all the
crime there well she really did this he
helped Lindsay and you know all that
well then she sort of failed in her
mission right sure I
I mean she well she did once with Jim
Sorry Sorry she did was with James Frey
and she let him know that uh yeah but I
I don't know I I think the problem is
also Lindsay's you know who knows what
her addiction and her real situation is
but there seems to be a component of it
where Fame is enabling the worst aspects
of her addictions and well I watched
some of the show and it's seemed to me
that this was not a that the way if you
really wanted to help Lindsay Lohan the
way to help her was not to put her on
like to take what's been driving her
crazy and then just blow it out times a
million it would be to remove her from
the spotlight and right so isn't that
something that sort of perverse I mean
Oprah must have thought of that like
you're gonna take like a Fame addicts
some other things to which she sort of
said she was or wasn't it wasn't really
Peter there and then you're gonna give
them more of that like isn't that a
little just as my devil's advocate there
is an aspect of accountability to it and
I think that I watch Real Housewives -
Beverly Hills
Kimbrel sad and Madea yeah I don't watch
the Tyler Perry no I don't it's just and
I know that it exists um Kim Richards
recovering alcoholic said the show
basically saved her life because she was
being filmed all the time she couldn't
secretly drink she couldn't avoid people
calling her an alcoholic on camera yeah
and it made her get treatment I don't
that's the normal course of action for
an addict I'm just saying like there is
there is an aspect of accountability
when you're filming someone that was
truly the greatest man alive the addicts
yes I call him Bravo Andy because that's
what his twitter used to be whatever
shirt going what do you guys how do you
personally deal with the trainwreck
people cuz like Amanda Bynes when she
was going off the rails and Bieber and
all that like I follow them on Twitter
just really purely for the jokes but
every now and again I do start like when
Amanda Bynes was really going down the
tubes I started feeling bad and I was
like I'm
a joke about her anymore cuz she
literally could just show up in a gutter
and then I like s I'll feel bad but how
do you because you want to be part of
the site guys right we're all in it and
I I think there's a difference between
someone like Justin Bieber who I know it
doesn't seem like there's an addiction
it doesn't seem like there's it seems
like he's kind of a smartass kid and he
does [ __ ] things around a grand scale
yeah I mean he is basically Dennis the
Menace with like a lot of money and no
accountability yeah
where is Lindsay Lohan and amanda Bynes
there seems to be some some actual
medical mental possibly issues at play
and that there's a difference between it
feels darker and meaner and it's the
same way when people joke about you know
like Miley Cyrus was in the hospital
recently for like a real like she had a
bad reaction to penicillin or something
but the the jokes immediately about you
know oh what the STDs are oh she's
pregnant with so-and-so's and and it
just becomes you know what if something
truly terrible happens to this first
thing I mean there's you have to kind of
factor a lot of things in you know it's
like how much of a dick is that person
so with Justin Bieber like he's a he is
a dick like that we don't feel guilty
for making fun of him with someone who's
clearly struggling I mean you have to
look at it and say like can I make a
joke and live with myself after doing so
and I think that I hold back for a lot
of people because I don't think I could
kind of cope with it
and then everyone's small there's
someone like Bieber is a great example
who just I mean where's there's no
sympathy for him like we're not worried
about him if he were clearly struggling
maybe I would step back but right now
he's just being Justin he's just a rich
and spoiled rich kid is a is a problem
but it's not like something you can you
can treat medically so it'd be great
yeah yeah but if a pill could fix him
give it to him but I don't think that's
gonna happen yeah alright well said
Bieber you're welcome to come on the
show anytime and defend yourself we'd
love to have you